the worsening economic crisis in sri
lanka the government has restricted the
sale of fuel
that comes days after the prime minister
said the economy has completely
collapsed
so what's caused the crisis and what are
the consequences this is inside story
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm hashem
sri lanka is facing an unprecedented
economic meltdown and people are
suffering petrol pumps are nearly dry
and the government has suspended the
sale of fuel for non-essential services
while it looks for supplies from russia
and qatar
it had already imposed electricity cuts
to save energy and food and medicines
are running short
people are angry especially those who
need fuel to earn a living and despite
pressuring a prime minister into
resigning workers and protesters want to
know why the same government is still in
place
this is a huge injustice fuel is an
essential item for the people if there
is no fuel the whole country comes to a
standstill people elected this
government with high hopes
it is because of the short-sighted
policies of the government that people
are spending days in line
people are helpless
they and their children can't do their
jobs or study i see this as a huge crime
i'm at the petrol station the wife is in
the gas cube the two children have gone
to the kerosene shed we can't afford
anything these days nobody's taking
responsibility for this i don't know
what the government is doing at least
put someone in charge who can do
something
our children don't have milk powder
there's no fuel for our husbands to do
their job we don't have gas to cook
women are in gas cues the man of the
house is in the fuel queue children are
in milk powder cues how can we live we
came to ask this government if they
can't govern then please leave they're
all thieves
we came to the prime minister's private
home to tell him about the injustice
done to us we don't have weapons or
water bottles or even sticks we are
peaceful protesters
we'll begin our discussion in a moment
let's look at how sri lanka got there
its vital tourism industry was already
in crisis following the civil war that
ended in 2009
the easter sunday bombings in 2019
and then the pandemic
but at the start of 2022 with oil and
food prices rising it suffered a sharp
drop in its foreign currency reserves
colombo defaulted on its falling debt
the government was unable to buy
essential food and medicines and without
fuel power cuts were imposed
the government saw the help of india
china and most recently the imf but with
little progress
in may weeks of protest led to the
resignation of prime minister mahinda
but the cost of living has continued to
soar
let's now get the thoughts of our guests
joining us in colombo is jihan pereira
executive director of the national peace
council of sri lanka in nottingham is
tamil ananta vinayagan lecture in the
international human rights law at the
university of nottingham in colombo
chayo dam singer economist at the
frontier research welcome to the program
jihan when the prime minister says that
the country's economy has completely
collapsed
what does that mean for sri lanka is it
a strong indication that the economy
itself has become now dysfunctional
well what we are very concerned about is
that the prime minister is saying the
economy has collapsed but he is not
saying what's going to be done about it
what is the plan forward we expected
this of him in fact when he was
appointed prime minister
a person who
was
has only one seat in parliament
but has been a prime minister five times
in the past
we expected and the people expected that
he would
be uh take us out of this morass that we
are in with his experience of governance
and his international connections his
knowledge about parliamentary procedure
and governance in general
but we have been very disappointed since
then because what we see since it's
taking over is a progressive
deterioration in the situation
the lines for petrol and diesel and
cooking gas are longer than ever i mean
in fact there have been no cooking gas
for the last two three weeks
um so
the power cuts are once again growing
the government has
said that government officials should
work from home for the next indefinite
period schools are closed universities
are growing it's absolutely shocking yes
so
when you say the economy is
collapsed i mean what does that mean you
you have to find a solution to this not
say nearly say that the economy has
collapsed and so we are really very
upset and disappointed people are very
angry about this because they expected
much more from from the prime minister
and from the government but what we also
see is that it's like almost politics as
usual
we expected a small interim government
an all-party government that would
govern for a short period of time but
what we are seeing is a big government
and
talks about more ministers being
appointed for what purpose
so we are actually quite upset
tamil is it fair to expect the prime
minister rani g to fix overnight
the structural problems and many years
of mismanagement in sri lanka
many thanks for this uh
thought-provoking question um i don't
think so
simply because ever since
post-independence like many other global
south countries uh sri lanka isn't the
chokehold of a third world elite that
has enriched itself but marginalized and
completely impoverished the peoples and
right now we are seeing the situation
where the people have to pay
the bill
for
a range of issues such as the the
populist tax cuts
the ban on chemical fertilizers
but also for the worldwide decline of
garment
rubber
and in the case of sri lanka i'm
exacerbating the situation we have seen
the pandemic that had some devastating
impact but also um the dwindling
income through tourism after the easter
bombings now all of this is contributing
to a situation that we have a toxic stew
in sri lanka that was um very much
instigated by a third world elite
renewed singer and others who are
currently at helm um like gian said
earlier
have just only contributed to a
situation where they have not really
explained what is going to happen now
um and i'm definitely to answer your
question not very positive that the same
people who have created the problems are
going to solve the problems in the very
near future
emit an international
orchestra
that is coming from the imf in the world
bank i certainly don't think that this
problem will be solved
uh nationally there needs to be an
international and in particular regional
effort uh in form of global assault
solidarity among regional states
chair now what would you expect the
prime minister to do when you look at
the picture and this is what you get a
very somber economic reality you don't
have revenues you don't have
uh currency foreign currency reserves
you've been battered economically the
tourism industry has suffered massively
you don't have you're not generating
revenues you don't have cash to pay for
services uh so how to move forward you
seem to be in a in a very vicious cycle
here
very much so i mean moving forward and
the fact that sri lanka has fallen down
to such a level uh our reserves
effective numbers might actually be
close to zero in terms of
are there's foreign in meeting rupee
payments other government has to its uh
state sector workers salaries
contractors all of that so when you're
at this point there's actually very
little that you can do you need as a
government as anyone to do to
immediately solve the issue like was
said but there are things that needed to
bring in confidence both for now but
also bringing some sort of resolution
for the future what we're seeing right
now is that neither of these are really
happening you need a budget to come in
really fast you need to move fast on
that restructuring negotiations you need
to move fast on making sure the welfare
net that we have that that helps the
world to survive in this kind of context
actually functions right now these are
things you need to move fast on and
that's not something to happen the
budget is now only expected interim
budget is only expected to come in
sometime in august when we realistically
should have had it at the very least
sometime in march or april but it that
kind of delay does not really bring
ahead even in the multilateral
engagement with the imf with the world
bank even with our creditors doesn't
really inspire confidence when you're
delaying things so far and then on the
local side but also with other partners
that you're dealing the fact that the
people are continuously calling for the
president to resign for actual change in
the governance system at least for a
short term to an interim arrangement
hasn't really worked and that's lead to
a complete crisis of confidence in the
local economy and that's part of the
reason why for example remittances
aren't flowing into the formal system
exporters do not have a confidence
interest keeping money abroad so things
that could help you not in the short
term are also not working because
there's a complete breakdown of trust in
the system the economic system the
political system and without these kinds
of things changing and without actual
action being taken on the economic front
fast without delay really there is no
practical way forward things will get
worse unless these things are moved on
jihan this these are challenging times
however they could provide some sense of
clarity particularly when it comes to
the future but i'd like to ask you this
question it was quite obvious since the
start of this crisis that one of the
fundamental problems with sri lanka is
that it relies heavily on imports but
ultimately does not have
enough revenues to pay for these revenue
for these imports last year you paid
something like 20 billion dollars for
the imports
but we don't have you don't have the
revenue to be able to do that anymore
yes you're perfectly right i mean this
is
this problem started long time ago it is
not uh
only this government that is responsible
or that has to blame for this this
problem started a long time ago when we
went in for the free market system
and
detached ourselves from our earlier
commitment
to a more egalitarian society we have
that we had a society that
was more
concerned about
preserving social welfare
socialist measures but even at that time
it was you're consuming more than you're
producing
and instead of focusing on
generating greater production uh we went
in for more trade type of
economy import export but importing more
and borrowing all the time we were
borrowing so we were ordered borrowing
and then with that with those borrowings
consuming
and along with that i think one very big
problem in our country has been the lack
of accountability
that
when politicians and public servants and
when they do engage in corruption
they are not punished so
along with the borrowings
we
we misallocated our resources we we went
in for grandiose projects airports
without passengers without planes coming
in ships without ports
the tallest tower in south asia without
uh being able to open it they were
huge amounts of infrastructure and also
a long detect corruption and in fact
where that is concerned i'm afraid that
chinese
the chinese role has been pretty bad
because they gave us money large amounts
of money without the necessary checks
and balances that that say private
sector investment would have all
multilateral aid would have brought with
it so the monies that we got we didn't
use it well
and now we can't repay all the loans
that we took and that's i think that's
at the core so and if you look at our
roads we have so many luxury vehicles
it's it's incredible suvs mercedes
benz's bmws the gap between the rich and
the poor has increased
so we have to restructure our economy
the way we think we need we need a new
generation
and so that's that's a desire that this
in fact that is epitomized in what the
young protesters are saying they said
the president must go
and also all 225 parliamentarians must
vote they are rejecting politics totally
tamil or could be the moment to reset
the economic and political priorities
because when you look at the rajapaksas
themselves they have
ruled over a political dynasty that
pursued an aggressive policy but then
we're getting indications that all those
policies backfired to the point where in
2019 they decided to massively cut taxes
which could have given the government
something like two billion dollars a
year they end up having something like
50 million in foreign currency today
which means they weren't
able to pay for anything they would like
to import
i mean you got a very good point and
though also previous speakers made very
good points um i mean
the third world elite in
post-independence sri lanka
is
is governed by dynasties and they have
passed on power from one to the other
and borrowed money from one to the other
and engaged in grandeur's
projects it's like giving a credit card
or several credit cards to a 16 year old
child that is this third world elite
right now
um and
in cooperation or in collaboration
rather with
the international monetary fund and the
world bank we have seen that there is a
new liberal
colonialism
a neo-colonial
colonialism
and encroaching upon
the people in sri lanka and the country
sri lanka as one of the speakers
mentioned before in the 1970s was one of
the first countries on the global
assault that had opened up to a new
liberal trading system
and
the majority majority elite sorry um had
used borrowed money in order to
intoxicate its people uh by using also
nationalist and and religious uh
extremism um in order to enrich
themselves
so
what i am fearing right now is
that the current government like
previous governments are
as gihan said mentioned earlier um not
accountable
and they won't be held any accountable
in the national setting as of now but
they are also dealing with an
international uh framework namely the
international monetary fund and the uh
world bank um and it is uh like thomas
sankara the great leader from bukhinaka
said once the origins of debt arise from
the origins of colonialism and those who
lend us money are the same was colonized
before and they are those who are used
to manage our stakes and economies and
while we have and completely
unaccountable um domestic elite we have
also an international lead that is
unable to um be held accountable chair
let's let's let's uh dissect some of
those components of this economic
failure you have
defaulting on debt payment at the same
time you cannot purchase fuel from
abroad just for the simple reason is
that your local
fuel company which is the ceylon
corporation is owed something like 700
million dollars to the point where
western companies are saying you have to
be careful dealing with sri lanka from
our own words
um yes i mean the the underlying factors
of our economy as previously said has
been around for a while i wouldn't
actually say we started in the 70s i
think it started much earlier than that
the fact that we had a very
import-driven system that that's not
only in terms of our
direct import consumption that is for
example the fuel for our cars but it's
also in terms of the raw materials even
for things like local production this
recent government that came in for
example had as one of its policy
priorities local production some
strong protectionist policies which
ultimately led to a lot of export taxes
uh having some issues with it it didn't
really lead to a lot of financing going
into those export activities but rather
into domestic consumption driven uh
policies into policies that expanded
upon that domestic consumption site now
the wall those tax cuts again aim
primarily at the rich and the idea that
growth will help you know you can have
better industrialization with tax cuts
but we are seeing right now the con the
consequences and what kind of
industrialization we're in i'm joining
this interview right now in a power cut
and that's not the kind of environment
that is conducive to any sort of growth
any source of development and the light
now a foreign exchange reserve that's a
key part of it that it fell down so low
because after 2019 after the tax cuts
really
you know
really brought down our financial status
as well as the impact of the pandemic
sri lanka was downgraded to a point
where we couldn't access international
capital markets so at that point what
sri lanka should have done is started
stalking to uh our creditors started
engaging with the imf and trying to come
some sort of solution to get out of the
crisis but rather we just doubled down
and we call them homegrown solutions but
we're seeing what those consequences of
the home good solutions are keeping the
exchange rate fixed uh for example using
up all our reasons to pay debt uh you
know to finance different different
kinds of things into what we call
non-tradable sectors uh you know things
that build up production but without any
real benefit in terms of the financial
income that the country itself gets and
we are at that point right now where the
consequences of all those decisions have
really
taken fragile economy worsened it and
now we're facing those consequences okay
we have many other angles to cover so
i'll ask you questions and i'll expect
to gentlemen to give me some offer me
some very brief answers if you don't
mind jihan
the prime minister is saying the only
option available now for sri lanka is
loans from international lenders this is
why they're talking to the imf and
others and you know the conditions that
come most of the time attached to those
loans
is it a good step forward
i think the way out for us is
is the international community the good
will have to now rely on the goodwill of
the internationals in fact
i mean we are being sustained and we
have been buffered for the last two
months
through indian credit lines i mean india
is itself not such a rich country and we
are really grateful that india has
stepped forward
to support us at this time of great
great need
ironically we
the imf used to be very controversial in
our country it still is to some extent
our people were told that if you go to
the imf they will impose all sorts of
conditions on you uh they will cut the
social welfare
they will make us
sort of neo liberal tie us with the west
but actually now people
in a way we want the imf to come in
because we think that if the imf comes
in
they will ensure that the loans that
they give that are given to us
will be used properly that need to not
be stolen it is so
bad and crude is that which we feel that
whatever foreign loans we get that it
will be robbed an imf with its systems
will ensure that that will not happen
and we think that even the other
countries okay us japan japan has said
first get imf then we will come in and
we think it remains
uncountable it remains debatable as you
know because people are really divided
about the notion of having to seek the
help from international
lenders
tamil you have 20 percent of sri lankans
who come from the middle class those
people had high hopes that life was
going to be much better that it could be
taking part in the political and
economic uh
sphere now they feel betrayed abandoned
by their political elite what's next for
them
well uh frankly um history shows us that
there will be um an economic turmoil
also for the middle class who had been
hoping to see
a
greater share
in the well
well-being of the state and the wealth
of the state
uh history has taught us from greece
argentina
peru
and
you know
eastern asian countries
where um and there i have to disagree
with
gion
vehemently because academic
um
research is pointing out to the
devastating impact imf world bank
have also in the middle class and also
the most vulnerable
because i do think that structural
adjustment programs
will not only
further
further the neoliberal ideology but also
cut more
on the state
leading to more impoverishment among the
people and the way forward
in my frank view
is
to forgive debt uh we have uh
surrendered us to the imf world bank
india china they're not doing this out
of good will and philanthropy they're
doing that because they want something
and that is structural adjustment
programs regional reasons so um
i to answer your question i'm frankly
afraid for the middle class and they are
going to see um a downfall in the
current economic structure
what does it mean when you have
inflation for
food hitting 57
uh
currently now in sri lanka
yeah i mean the significant part the
main reason for the inflation in sri
lanka is the fact that over the last two
years sri lanka the sri lankan
government decided that the best way
forward was to print a massive amount of
money trillions of rupees uh were
printed the budget deficit was monetized
through that by cutting taxes we printed
money instead and that's been absolutely
massive and the thing is the fact that
we come down to such a low point means
that it's actually quite difficult to
reverse that kind of situation without
actually having massive revenue raising
measures and right now we can't have
massive revenue raising measures
especially ones that are bringing
revenue a lot at this
in the short term which means the fact
that progressive taxation while a good
idea it takes time to really increment
and bring it okay so you might see
further inflation coming up and that's
obviously really really terrible for the
citizens of the country those of us who
live here will have to deal with the
consequences of the very protection is
inward looking at an anti-international
policies that the country has decided to
go into it would be a mammoth task to
see the prime minister reversing those
trends because when you look at this
current situation debt is at 51 billion
current consumer inflation 30 and the
foreign currency reserves stands at
something like 50 million thank you very
much indeed jihan pereira tamil and
taviagan and chai you dam singh i really
appreciate your insight
and thank you for watching you can see
the program again any time by visiting
our website aljazeera.com for further
discussion go to our facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash aj
inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside sorry for me hashem ahabala
and the entire team
here in doha bye for now
[Music]
you